et la dame la caissière me dit je ne
peux pas vous avez pas 18 ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au trône le très propre prince William
et entre les deux rien ne va plus
il faut dire que dans son livre Harry et
corne la belle image que ses bâti son
frère est né en révélant trop de que ce
dernier l'aurait frappé pour William le
gendre idéal de l'Angleterre c'est la
sortie médiatique de trop il serait fou
de rage et ne voudrait plus entendre
parler de son petit frère mais il y a
deux bureaux de presse un pour William
et un pour Harry c'est ça ce qu'on
apprend et que le bureau de presse de
William qui est beaucoup plus important
parce qu'il va être roi envoie des
saloperies sur Harry pour lui l'abîmer
et ne pas abîmer Buckingham c'est ce que
dit Harry
peut vraiment répondre à cette question
reste du palais qui peut vraiment
répondre à cette question là avec des
preuves à la fin
qui ne peut même pas répondre il n'a pas
le droit qui constitue ces mêmes et
réduit au silence ça va aller Bertrand
ça va aller pour info celui qui écrit
livre qui est très bien écrit après 5h
oui après 5 millions d'euros pour
l'écrire
parce que en fait dans ce livre il a eu
besoin de l'écrire par par souci de
vérité ils s'en sont pris tellement la
famille
il va avoir un psy aussi quand la
plupart des people écrivent des
biographies pour raconter tout ce qu'ils
ont vécu ça j'ai une personne là parce
que c'est Harry ça gêne moi je le trouve
extrêmement touchant dans sa démarche et
franchement dire ce que tu dis c'est de
pas considérer que derrière l'aspect
Royal qu'il a il n'est pas un humain et
ça je trouve ça regrettable
dans le livre que William est circoncis
qu'est-ce qu'il a besoin de venir me
dire ça c'est ce qui nous dit oui est-ce
qu'il a pas de venir nous dire que le
jour de son mariage William était bourré
alors s'il vous plaît
il y a des images contournées récemment
est-ce que tu m'autorises à la passer
pourquoi parce que ça aurait été le
meilleur moyen
je vais vous expliquer quelque chose
et là chez moi je vais reprendre du poil
de la bête je vais mettre à côté de toi
il se passe un truc
en fait je te parle à toi
je parle au public c'est à dire que
maintenant les nouveaux paparazzis
ce sont les téléphones portables c'est
là la caméra non
[Rires]
je rentre dans un Super Market je viens
de terminer quasiment les funérailles et
la préparation le deuil de Coolio et de
Ronnie donc j'ai le cœur très lourd je
veux acheter une toute petite bouteille
d'alcool 20 et la dame la caissière me
dit je ne peux pas vous avez pas 18 ans
j'ai presque 60 ans
c'est une joke elle m'a dit tu n'as pas
ta carte d'identité il y a rien
qu'est-ce qu'il y en a marre quand
deviennent losers et je suis parti mais
en fait c'est à dire que maintenant on
enregistre les gens et on met des bulles
on met des bulles alors les bulles comme
dans les dans les dessins animés ou à
l'époque les BD elle a dit ça elle a dit
je n'ai même pas prononcé un mot on me
voit partir naturelle il y en a marre et
je pars
de diffamation de fausses informations
oui mais ce qui s'est passé ce qui s'est
dit surtout en fait dans cette dans
cette émission c'est que il y avait pas
une mignonnette mais plusieurs
millionnaires que tu n'avais pas ta
carte d'identité mais surtout que ta
carte de crédit n'est pas passée et que
c'est une femme derrière qui s'est
proposée et que quand tu es parti tu as
eu des propos un petit peu antisémites
par rapport au vendeur
c'était tellement énervé que j'ai mis ma
carte j'ai retiré la carte et j'ai jeté
la bouteille mais tout ça c'est
diffamation c'est pas vrai je mets toi
tu as dit qu'en fait elle était pas
passée parce que tu avais atteint un
plafond mais pas du tout j'ai pas de
plafond j'ai 100000 euros sur une carte
normale rien à voir
adopte moi
elle m'a dit je vais te massacrer je
veux que tu t'excuses je lui dis moi je
m'excuser jamais elle m'a dit si tu
t'excuses pas je te black bol sur
internet j'ai dit je ne perdrai jamais
ma dignité
est-ce que c'est vrai que tu as dit tu
as sorti ton Instagram en disant moi
j'ai besoin d'une carte vous avez pas
qui je suis je suis une stage j'ai un
million de followers
ah non j'ai dit mais j'ai pas 17 ans
j'ai 60 ans espèce de clocharde et j'ai
jeté ma bouteille j'espère que Macron
nous regarde j'aimerais que dire
Président chers Président j'aimerais que
vous fassiez une loi que tous les gens
avec un portable qui nous filme dans des
endroits publics ou privés soit comme à
Dubaï dans les pays arabes doivent payer
une amende de 5000 euros afin de
respecter notre droit à l'image et à
vélo appeler ça la loi Afida Turner
[Applaudissements]
la semaine dernière la star du foot
Cristiano Ronaldo rejoint le club dalle
Nasser en Arabie donc c'est le président
du PSG jusqu'en 2025 les chiffres de son
nouveau contrat donnent le tournis c'est
200 millions d'euros de salaires par an
voilà et il a présenté donc hier
après-midi au King sound University
Stadium il a présenté ça et vous allez
voir c'est assez incroyable parce que en
fait ils ont créé une mini ville pour
lui un super marché c'est comme si vous
étiez dans une ville à Nancy mais c'est
que pour vous regardez
[Musique]
mais ma femme ma famille et moi on
aimerait tous vous remercier pour votre
soutien pour votre accueil
et on donnera le meilleur de nous-mêmes
merci merci à tous mais il a pas de
valeur regarde son compte Instagram non
mais regarde les publicités dans
lesquelles il tourne etc c'est
absolument pas un modèle d'ailleurs il
est pas particulièrement idolâtre par la
jeunesse c'est plus Messi Mbappe qui
sont dans les dans les petits papiers
des jeunes aujourd'hui Cristiano Ronaldo
tout le monde a envie d'être aussi fort
que lui mais est-ce qu'on a envie de lui
ressembler c'est qu'en fait on est en
train de voir que dès qu'on a de
l'argent bah il y a plus de valeur il y
a des machins il y a plus de principes
c'est un pays hyper méga conservateur ou
les femmes n'ont pas le droit d'être
la consommation d'alcool est interdite
etc mais quand c'est Ronaldo qu'il est
extrêmement riche et Machin bon bah là
alors
un pardonnable injuste inadmissible ce
sont les sentiments qu'on ressenti les
fans de Céline Dion en découvrant le
classement établi par Rolling Stones le
célèbre magazine musical américain des
200 meilleurs chanteurs de tous les
camps dans lequel ne figurez pas la star
québécoise pas choqué parce que je pense
que Rolling Stones j'aurai très
particulier les gens qui aiment bien la
musique et une certaine musique etc et
qui s'estime qu'elle n'a pas marqué
l'histoire de la musique ça s'arrête
tout simplement là ça veut pas dire que
c'est pas une des plus grandes
chanteuses du monde et une des plus
grandes vendeuses du monde elle a juste
pas être pour Rolling Stones pas marqué
l'histoire de la musique dans le plan de
Céline Dion on pense qu'elle n'est pas
dans ce classement à cause de sa
résidence à Las Vegas ça félicite ça le
génie une fois
autre chose et dernière chose il y a
Madonna n'est pas dans le classement il
y en a beaucoup d'autres qui ne sont pas
dans ce classement donc on est là parce
qu'en ce moment on parle beaucoup de
Céline Dion mais est-ce que Céline Dion
est un génie non mais est-ce que Céline
Dion est un génie une génie
les chiffres et il y a le talent elle a
les deux elle a les deux c'est à dire
qu'elle a fait des records mais elle a
une voix enfin unique en son genre
Rolling Stones c'est des intellos c'est
comme voilà c'est quand on lit les
quatre bien sûr c'est comme les Inrock
c'est comme ce genre de canard etc donc
à un moment donné je pense que Céline
Dion elle est trop populaire c'est la
populace c'est les gens qui l'aiment etc
mais tout le monde l'adore en vrai
Céline